[Applaudissements]
quand je l'ai su déjà du soulagement de
faire partie de l'équipe enfin des 32
qui partent en Nouvelle-Zélande
et fierté de pouvoir représenter
la France et dans un événement dans un
très grand événement comme ça
on sait que on sait qu'il y aura il y
aura de la pression par rapport à cette
terre de rugby et que ça va être
vraiment hyper immédiatisé hyper suivi à
la fois c'est super cool pour le pour le
rugby féminin à la fois bah il va on
sait que on va être hyper suivi donc ça
nous met une petite pression en
supplémentaire mais ouais forcément
c'est top c'est un pays j'ai déjà été
j'avais adoré donc c'est trop cool d'y
retourner
moi je le vois plutôt comme de la
motivation c'est la première fois que
j'ai livré un événement comme ça
je pense que la pression elle arrivera
peut-être quand on va commencer les
matchs et quand il y aura des un peu
plus d'enjeux mais là pour le moment je
le ressens comme plutôt comme une chance
vraiment de faire partie de ce groupe et
une opportunité de progression d'un mois
ma carrière individuelle
[Musique]
l'objectif c'est d'être championne du
monde oui on y croit on se prépare pour
ça après on a un groupe on a un groupe
une poule déjà assez relevée avec rien
que l'Angleterre ça va être costaud et
même l'Afrique du Sud c'est une très
bonne équipe les Fidji je connais pas
j'ai jamais joué après je pense que
pareil c'est une terre de rugby donc ça
doit bien jouer au rugby il faudra qu'on
soit très bonne dès le début et ces
trois matchs nous permettront du coup de
de grandir rugbytiquement et
collectivement pour faire des grosses
performances après sur l'écart les demi
et la finale j'espère
c'est de participer au plus de
rencontres possible
il y a quand même on est 32 joueuse il y
aura que 23 places sur la feuille de
match on sait qu'il y en a qui joueront
peut-être pas du tout la Coupe du Monde
il y en a qui joueront peut-être que que
très très peu donc forcément c'est de
faire des bons entraînements faire des
feuilles de match pour jouer et pour
pour essayer de tout donner sur le
terrain
[Applaudissements]